so yup has also where we where we going
next here with the weight empty so
what's what's coming there are a couple
of obvious things always there's a need
for better quality everywhere there is a
need for more languages better language
coverage what's important for me easy
access in the sense of Mt is not a it's
not a destination it's a feature it
should be part of your workflow you're
not doing you don't nobody wants raishin
but everybody wants to understand what
is being said so it needs to be there
needs to be accessible and certainly I
don't think we're quite there yet making
that making empty easily accessible so
they and that is a to a large extent up
to the up to the providers making it
systematically accept accessible and to
the integrators in exposing it in the
most useful fashion in whatever whatever
they the right workflow is I think the
demonstration of the of the of the
doctor-patient interaction that we saw
today is a very good example of how how
our providers and integrators can make
it a really good experience and we need
more of it then another aspect of it is
the collaborative collaborative
architectures that ways for us to share
feedback to share data to consume data
and to generate the right ater for using
it and enabling community is to work
together and that's something that that
really is shared between between bill
and he mentioned it yesterday that's the
that's the danger of a divide between
the data poor languages and the data
rich languages we can do very well for
French German Spanish Portuguese Italian
Japanese Chinese but then really it
it it it goes down from from there in
terms of quality and things we can do
once you go to two Estonian so Haley
even Hindi all right it gets it gets a
lot a lot worse right and a couple a
couple of different things that can be
can be done yet so certainly for the
data rich languages we can we can push
the quality significantly with domain
adaptation customization we've heard a
lot about that here already thought and
we need to need to go into into details
they are and they are a couple of I
think very interesting approaches to
deal better with the data poor languages
and that's around comparable mining so
where you don't have where you don't
have exactly parallel data but you have
a comparable data meaning a say an
article about the same topic but not a
translation of each other so there are
elements you can mine from there to to
synthesize parallel data as a result so
that's interesting research going on in
that space that makes this better usable
the bootstrapping of low resource
languages so if a if a low resource
languages is similar to another language
you can borrow from the you can borrow
from that other languages our team has
had pretty good success they are in in
building a Haitian Creole system based
on a French background background data
google has talked about building a year
system based on based on a German and in
Hebrew and some other language so these
days there are opportunities they are
too to help but but is a there is a I
would say not yet the Smashing tangible
success out of it but interesting
research happening there then what's
what's happening in with the whole empty
machinery the technologies that are
developed
in the mt and i should say empty and
speech space because there are a lot of
a lot of similarity speech recognition
is what i mean and that's where i want
to i want to show you something it's
called contextual these hours or
paraphrasing and it works works
surprisingly well it's built on on
parallel data but it is in fact a
monolingual English to English
translation Rose was joking about it
it's not really meant a to translate
between us english and UK english okay
let's see what it does okay so what what
it comes up with here is a bunch of
alternative expressions that mean the
same thing but let the last it's it's
ranked by by likelihood of being good so
you wanna you want to stay up in there
in the in the in the upper range here so
there's certainly a more pervasive than
my for your daughter can can come up
with and this is what bill meant here by
the kind of back to the past you can you
can nicely navigate the tree here right
of all the candidates and you can you
can go here so it constructed
constructed the whole the whole tree
anymore whatever you choose a decent
candidate comes out of it so it's very
nice what is it good for of course of
course it's useful in the in the
consumer space you find different
expressions how to say something similar
to a word-based resolve so you saw a
work-based azores pessoa are pretty
common plates this is a phrase-based as
always you you write something and you
find come
with different ways to say to say a
similar thing helps english as a second
language speakers or whatever think at
language speakers to come up with better
with better better formulation another
application really is in this in the
space of understanding right
understanding means you get some some
input the shallow definition of
understanding is you get some input you
messaged you map it to a grammar and the
grammar creates an action whatever open
the document i was working on yesterday
that is about about my dentist treatment
right the system is supposed to find out
what what they do is they a map it map
it to the grammar in whatever way I said
it you can write a relatively simple
grammar that that defines the execution
steps if you find a if you can map the
input to the grammar that you have
defined you can do that by looking at
all the all the paraphrases and taking
something that means the same thing okay
so this is this helps really advance the
language understanding piece let me show
you another example which i think is
pretty interesting and may be
interesting for roles so Rose can can
rent a car in the US and in the UK but
they're also the list the list here is
pretty good all right you can try it for
yourself go to lab store Microsoft
translator com just just remember that
and then and then click on click on the
solos a player on with it if you don't
believe me that I that I picked only
there well working phrases I pick
phrases that that that work well but and
you will find something you will find
some that don't work that well but many
of them actually do work well